Nos piden graficar y = 3 • sin (½x) -2 en el
graficador interactivo que encontrarás en Khan
Academy. Pero antes vamos a mencionar cómo
funciona este graficador: este punto aquí te
ayuda a definir la línea media alrededor de lo que
oscila tu función seno o coseno, y luego defines
un punto extremo cercano, que será el punto máximo o
mínimo para graficar tu función. Así que pensemos
en cómo haríamos esto y, como siempre, te invito a
que pauses el video y trates de resolverlo por tu
cuenta. Pero una forma de pensar en esto es: si
esto sólo dijera y = sin (x), ¿cómo graficarías
eso? Bueno, el seno de 0 es 0, el seno de π /
2 es 1, y luego el seno de π es 0 nuevamente.
Así es como se vería el seno de x normal. Ahora
pensemos qué es diferente aquí. Bueno, en primer
lugar no es sólo sin (x), es sin (½x), entonces,
¿cuál sería la gráfica del sin (½x)? Bueno,
en realidad hay dos formas de pensar en ello:
una es que el coeficiente del término x te dice
qué tan rápido está creciendo lo que se ingresa en
el seno, esto crecerá la mitad de rápido, por lo
que su periodo será el doble de largo. Entonces,
una forma de verlo es que, en lugar de llegar al
siguiente punto máximo de π / 2, llegará allí en
π, y puedes probar esto: cuando x = π esto será
½π, seno (½π) es, de hecho, igual a 1. Otra forma
de pensar en esto es si estás familiarizado con
la fórmula, aunque siempre es mejor deducir de
dónde vienen estas fórmulas. Que para calcular
el periodo de una función seno o coseno, tomas 2π
y lo divides entre lo que sea este coeficiente:
2π / ½ va a ser 4π, y puedes ver el periodo aquí:
subimos, bajamos y volvemos a donde estábamos en
4π. Y eso tiene sentido porque, si sólo tuvieras
un coeficiente 1 aquí, tu periodo sería 2π,
y 2π radianes completan un círculo unitario. Así
que aquí tenemos la gráfica del seno (½ x). Ahora,
¿qué pasaría si queremos pensar en tres veces
la gráfica del sin (½ x) o 3 sin (½ x)? Bueno,
entonces nuestra amplitud será tres veces mayor,
en lugar de que nuestro punto máximo esté en 1
ahora estará en 3. Otra forma de pensarlo es que
estamos 3 unidades por encima de la línea media y
3 unidades por debajo de la línea media, así que
esta de aquí es la gráfica de 3 sin (½ x). Ahora
nos queda una cosa por hacer, y es considerar
este -2, entonces este -2 va a desplazar todo
hacia abajo dos unidades, así que tenemos
que mover todo hacia abajo. Y ahí lo tienes;
observa que el periodo sigue siendo 4π. Nuestra
amplitud o qué tanto oscila por encima o por
debajo de la línea media sigue siendo 3. Y ahora
tenemos este -2. Otra forma de pensarlo es que
cuando x = 0, todo este primer término va a ser
0 y y debería ser igual a -2. Y hemos terminado.